do you have anything to say to kids if
they're having gender dysphoria and
they're in school and they're being
encouraged to do surgery do you have
anything to say to kids considering
surgery this would be pointing more at
the parents what you should do is have
your kids saying Hey what if you had a
permanent tattoo across your face with
something like just big label every time
somebody saw you they saw that giant
labeled across your face it was it was
the only thing they could really see and
then see how you feel see how people
treat you see how it all fits in and
just the conversation alone would be
well a permanent tattoo across my face
why would I want to do that it's
something that's very permanent and it's
right there it's in front of everybody
and it's something that's really hard to
change